quand frédéric allume la télé c'est
toujours un peu la loterie
et même lorsqu'elle fonctionne ça ne
dure jamais longtemps
et toc s'arrêter s'est assis frère
partira où elle ne reportera pas la
faute au manque de débit dans la commune
quand il s'est installé à jumeaux on lui
avait promis la fibre sous six mois
deux ans plus tard derrière son sourire
il commence à perdre patience
l'internet c'est paris s'affiche souvent
ça on ne peut pas regarder ce qu'on veut
on veut je voulais ouvrir mail il faut
trois jours pour qu'ils sont c'est
désagréable
voilà mes bons et paris ça va les mains
car la fibre optique sera déployé sur
toute la côte d'or d'ici 2022 un
investissement de 220 millions d'euros
pour le département à jumeaux les
travaux d'installation sont bien avancés
priorité aux communes ayant un débit
inférieur à 8 méga ils pourront du coup
non seulement avoir la télévision mais
aussi faire toutes les démarches
administratives
via le réseau internet de façon plus
rapide de pouvoir transférer des données
de façon plus rapide le la fibre optique
à la maison permet d'avoir un débit de 1
giga ce qui est complètement différent
par rapport à avant sans ce très haut
débit difficile désormais d'attirer des
entreprises ou de nouveaux habitants
marque schott ans conseiller municipal
et ancien maire du village on a bien
conscience
la période de confinement n'a fait que
confirmer son ressenti quand les gens
ont demandé s'il ya commerce ici là la
question d'après c'est est-ce qui a la
fibre et c'est vraiment un handicap de
ne pas avoir la fibre surtout en ce
moment où il ya des gens qui sont lé
travail des enfants qui monopolisent
appelé l'installation pour faire leur
devoir maintenant c'était vraiment un
gros problème
frédéric pourra se raccorder à la fibre
à la mi-décembre 50 communes au total
seront équipées avant la fin de l'année
sur les 400 prises en charge par le
département